Mẹ ra gí lại quynh khách thay nạn lên hoàn giữa bà ô tô trên Quốc lộn 1a, đoạn qua sẽ ăn châu.
Sáng hay tháng ba, ô tô bày chỗ trải trên Quốc lộn 1 theo hướng bắt nằm khi đến cú vực châu cóm giễn thịn,
ô tô bất ngờ bị một semen trải cùng châu tâm mạnh từ phía sau để văn lên dài phân cách.
Chưa dừng lại, semen thức tục lào lên dài phân cách rồi và trăm chực dịch với một semen khác trải theo hướng nghiệp lại.
Vô tay nạn kiến tại sế năm 2020 của semen kê tay nạn từ vong, hình người trên các phương tiện còn lại bị mắc kẹt trong các bên,
hình thương nằm.
Chè là câu, các nạn là gì, lưu dùi viên, khi sẽ bài tổ đi cùng diện,
và tin hồi được hát của mình thương nạn, thế dây dây dây bản thình như thế,
cóm đi chật con phần nạn đó, với đẹp là gì là...
Tại hiện chương, bà ô tô hướng hộn nạn, phần đầu biến dạc, mạnh bữa phân xa phản bột chăm mét,
một số cuộc đen và biến báo xa thông cũng bị hút đồ.
Vinh nhân tay nạn đang được lần sống.